self-defense is not some fun boxing
match okay this is about escaping with
your life so strike scream and run
all right let's try it
it may have been my fault what the hell
Toby
um
what gives what
what gives you the right
sure you know what that sounds good
here we go thank you
what would you improve
about
under Mifflin uh
um
no I'm not asking it I'm just reading it
out loud oh I'd like to hear the answer
well let me see
I guess everything's okay inside the FBI
agent Michael scarn sits with his feet
up on his desk Catherine Zeta Jones
enters
sir you have some
okay what are they
first message is I love you that's for
me not in a thousand years Catherine we
work together and get off my desk yes I
have acted before I was in a production
of Oklahoma in the seventh grade
I played the part of Muti the mailman
they had too many kids so they made up
roles like that
that was good
if it isn't my old partner Samuel L
Chang
you lost some weight
thank you for noticing like a rap a rap
rhyme Urban thing an urban yeah Stanley
you want to help us out with that
Stanley Eartha Stanley not me yes you
come on Stanley put your little game
down and join the group no Stanley we're
just having a little bit more I've been
a brainstorm session
good this is good I'm going to grab a
glass of water
yes we do what
oh
I did it
see
I'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on Dwight come on man but I
really want honestly Michael is for you
to know it so that you can communicate
it to the people here to your clients to
whomever oh okay what
it's whoever not whomever not whomever
no whomever is never actually right no
sometimes it's right Michael is right
it's a made-up word used to trick
students actually whomever is the formal
version of the word obviously it's a
real word but I don't know when to use
it correctly I'm not a native speaker I
know what's right but I'm not going to
say because you're all jerks who didn't
come see my band last night do you
really know which one is correct I don't
know it's whom when it's the object of
the sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well it sounds right
but is it how did Ryan use it as an
object as an object Chinese me as an
object is he right about that how did he
use it again it was Ryan wanted Michael
the subject to explain the computer
system the object guilt to whomever
meaning us the indirect object which is
the the correct usage of the work no one
uh asks you anything ever so whomever's
name is Toby why don't you take a letter
opener and stick it into your skull wait
this doesn't matter come on Michael
you're you're interrupting you're
kidding me God
you say right on as silent but deadly
and then you expect me not to make
farting noises with my mouth what is
this you know what we're not gonna die
of radon we're going to die boredom yeah
right
and if I had a gun with two bullets and
I was in a room with Hitler Bin Laden
and Toby I would shoot Toby twice
okay all right really funny and then you
went too far I would kill Bin Laden and
then Toby no it's still okay Geniuses
how would you do it curve the bullet
like in my favorite James McAvoy film I
wanted
but all that does is help you shoot
around things but there's been a lot is
there a curtain rod in the room I don't
know how about make-believe land as
anything you want Stanley please this is
serious is this the thing where they use
an icicle so there's no evidence yes we
stabbed Toby from the Harvard in high
school bullet thing is a red herring
here's how you do it you line them all
up you take one bullet shoot them all
through the throat at the same time
watch this Phyllis your Hitler come up
here Toby you're Toby Andy You're Bin
Laden line up I don't want to throat's
together Toby just do it Toby come on
God ready one bullet and boom
okay
thank you thank you thank you get in the
cars get in the car thank you thank you
very much okay thanks for filling things
out and I promise this will be quick at
diversity today our philosophy is about
honesty and positive expectations we
believe that 99 of the problems in the
workplace arise simply out of ignorance
you know what this is a color-free Zone
here
race uh
see that this is what I'm talking about
we don't have to pretend that we're
colorblind exactly that's fine ignorance
with more
no with more ignorance right exactly uh
instead we need to celebrate our
diversity let's celebrate right okay
celebrate good times come on let's
celebrate diversity right yes exactly
now here's what we're gonna do uh I've
noticed that uh you know what here's
what we're gonna do why don't we go
around and everybody everybody
say a race that you are attracted to
sexually I will go last
I'm prison Mike
you know why they call me prison Mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall
all right hey
it's just the way we talk in the clink
but a lot of fun talk about prison today
but I'm here to scare you straight
in prison you are somebody's
oh and you you my friend would be de
Belle of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap Michael please
where did you learn all of this internet
so not prison and prison at 50 50
Bolt look prison stinks is what I'm
saying it's not like you can go home and
recharge your batteries and come back in
the morning and be with your friends
having fun in the office
what'd you do prison Mike
I stole
and I robbed
and I kidnapped the president's son
and held him for a ransom
that is quite the rap sheet prison Mike
and I never got caught neither well
they're in prison but prison Mike what
was the food like in prison gruel
sandwiches
gruel omelets nothing but gruel plus you
can eat your own hair
wow
prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you Andy thanks for the Mike
what's the very very worst thing about
prison
the worst thing about prison was that
was the Dementors they were flying all
over the place and they were scary and
then they come down and they sucked the
soul out of your body and at height okay
too fast everyone we need to pump at a
pace of 100 beats per minute oh okay
that's uh hard to keep track how many is
that per hour How's that gonna help you
I will divide and then count to it right
okay well a good trick is to pump to the
tune of Staying Alive by the Bee Gees
I do I love that song
first I was afraid I was petrified no
it's
Staying Alive you were in the parking
lot earlier that's how I know you
staying alive staying alive
staying alive
oh you can't tell by the way I use my
walk I'm a woman's brand new type of
talk what is it loud women more been
kicked around since I was born when it's
all right it's okay you can't live the
other way
okay you didn't maintain 100 beats per
minute and the ambulance didn't arrive
because nobody called 9-1-1 so you lost
them okay he's dead anyone know what we
do next anybody Rose I have no idea
anyone else we bury him wrong and check
for an organ donor card if he has one we
only have minutes to harvest he has no
wallet I checked he is an organ donor he
is yeah give me some ice in a styrofoam
bucket
here we go
we search for the organs where's the
heart
this is hard I'm not feeling well I need
to sit down
are you okay
oh my God